the B fluid as water that is at the
tagline of the film or that's just a
state did you say that in the movie no
I'm definitely not said that in the
movie oh you have it okay um so beef
beef fluid as water is currently the
tagline but because the word sulig is
icky Daaga may be difficult to pronounce
internationally it depends we may we may
put it as the English title of the film
it's the world sulig is succeed agha
means caught in the whirlpool that's
what that means so it's almost as if
when caught in the whirlpool
be fluid as water that's the kind of the
connection you know of course if you see
the film is when you'll understand the
whole the whole connection of all of
this but the B fluid is water I feel so
proud to say this in an interview
because I am one of the biggest admirers
of the legend Bruce Lee and one of his
most famous speeches has this this
phrase that he uses be water my friend
and if you hear that speech it pretty
much encompasses what you need to be in
life flexible adaptable flowing forward
usually what it doesn't go backward you
know and I think he says that he said he
encompasses it all in that speech so
beautifully and I was very inspired by
that speech and since my film deals with
four major components one of those
components is inspired by his love of
martial arts which which I've taken in
my heart as something amazing you know
and that martial arts angle is what made
me use this tagline because once people
see the film they'll understand that the
martial arts component is what connected
to this tag line as be fluid as water
that doesn't mean the storyline doesn't
also encompasses line it does but it was
kind of a very I would like to call it
intelligent way of combining those
things the B fluid as water
you